[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning's the race
is on to administer covet vaccines to
elementary school children doctors
offices vaccine sites and pharmacies
providing the first visor doses to kids
ages 5 to 11 years old after the cdc
endorse her use lead national
correspondent that's david bagno spoke
to one louisiana family who had a very
complicated journey to get the vaccine
david good morning to you
good morning to you a story with a twist
that's what we've got for you this
morning listen when the vials for these
kids first arrived at the health
department here in cajun country there
was a group of kids who literally ran to
the front door they couldn't wait to get
the shot
oh my gosh i'm so excited
you have probably never seen kids so
excited all right hudson
to get a shot i didn't count i'm sorry
that's it it's over i didn't even feel
it
how was it that is fine
one of them is 10 year old ella conrad
of broussard louisiana that shot means
her life is going to change
she hasn't played with her friends for a
year and a half and that is because she
has ulcerative colitis diagnosed at the
age of three she takes medication that
suppresses her immune system covet posed
a serious danger to ella so her mother
stacy has only allowed her to do
individual activities since the pandemic
began nice it's been real hard watching
her struggle through this
so i'm really excited ella was already
homeschooling because of concerns about
how the flu might affect her covid
scared the family far more i know that
if my child gets coveted once she's
fully vaccinated that her risk of having
severe covet is minimal now she didn't
always feel that way in fact at the
start of the pandemic stacy conrad
didn't believe in kovid at all in the
very beginning i kind of believed the
hype that it was
a conspiracy let's delve into that
conspiracy yeah you went down the whole
q anon road yes i did
i did you thought what at the wildest
points i believed that jfk was gonna was
going to come back from the dead i
wanted to believe
what the scientists were saying i wanted
to believe what the government officials
were telling us i wanted to believe all
of this stuff
but
i also didn't want to shelter my kid and
keep her inside so i was trying to prove
that it wasn't so and hearing the q anon
conspiracies made it easier for me to
not believe just some of the things that
the
there were going to be three days of
darkness
you know people told me there was there
was going to be darkness and and ella
had heard about this and she was she was
terrified i was just terrified i did not
want to go outside like anymore is that
when you started sleeping in your mom's
room yeah
it was wild yeah what exactly helped you
see the light so to speak finally one
day my husband was like yo
this is bizarre y'all this is crazy so
she started listening to doctors and
following the science you went from q
anon believing right to a vaccine
advocate for the state of louisiana
how bizarre is that
that's a wild turnaround yeah i decided
to put my energy into what was real and
what was in front of me the facts the
facts she now travels throughout
southwest louisiana educating people in
underserved communities about the
vaccine and even helps them book an
appointment to get vaccinated
her most personal appointment yet is
ella who got vaccinated alongside her
friend kiki and kiki's brothers hudson
and cooper
their dad is a doctor who has been
treating cogan patients
they are the children of frontline
workers who were among the first in
louisiana to be vaccinated in their age
group we want to get vaccinated so we
can hurry up and have a sleepover i hear
you
you know because of ella's compromised
immune system her doctor has said she'll
probably need four coveted shots over a
series of months to where she's in a
safe place because of her immune system
being compromised by the medication and
here in louisiana they've been given
adults a hundred dollars as an incentive
to get vaccinated well they're giving it
to the kids too five years old come and
get a shot 100 bucks is yours
guys back to you
boy david i am so fascinated by ella's
mom's thanking stacy did she happen to
mention why she believed that jfk junior
was coming back
from the dead i i'm fascinated by this
um
gail her neighbors believed it she
believed it and she'll tell you that she
was susceptible right she was
susceptible but she started to say wait
a minute even this has sounded a little
weird so as she said but show me but
show me the proof if you're telling me
it's only old people dying show me the
numbers and once she started to see the
science then she went to the other
extreme from one extreme to another
and she was motivated she was motivated
to find a conclusion that fit what she
wanted to believe so she found the
evidence what we always say is it's not
all it's not going to be the experts
that disprove this for people it's going
to be a trusted source her husband was
the one who was like listen this is
crazy as parents we have to be careful
about the fear we pass down to our kids
absolutely david that's a great story
thank you very much very eye opening